Do you remember this one?
(Laughter)
It's a Nokia 3310.
Once recognized as the greatest
phone ever produced.
I guess most of you
in this room owned one, didn't you?
Please raise your hand
if you owned a 3310.
Wow, so almost 100 percent
market share here.
(Laughter)
So you'll remember
that it never ran out of battery.
(Laughter)
You could play Snake on it.
It was world-famous for being
the indestructible phone.
So in the mobile industry,
the saying used to go
that if someone drops an iPhone,
the screen breaks.
If someone drops a Nokia 3310,
the floor breaks.
It was unbelievably solid.
The 3310 embodied exactly
what Nokia stood for as a brand:
resilience, quality and innovation.
It was products like this one
that turned Nokia into one
of the most successful companies
on the planet.
But as you will also remember,
there is another and a more
tragic side to this story.
Because today, the 3310 rests in peace
at the gadget's graveyard.
It's become a symbol
of the collapse of Nokia,
a company that went from 50 percent
global market share
to three percent in less than five years.
And it made me think that,
while we talk a lot about how
an organization achieves success,
maybe we don't talk enough
about the psychological challenges
that often follow success.
Because if you think about it,
almost every industry
has its own Nokia story.
Companies that once
dominated their industry
but then somehow completely lost the mojo.
They all leave us
with that million dollar question.
Why do successful companies actually fail?
And what could they have done
to stay ahead of the pack?
So I'm going to try
and answer that question today,
not by using traditional
management thinking
but by using an idea
from football analytics,
which I believe explains
why many successful companies
so often hesitate to change
until it's too late.
Before I start, I need to ask
a very important question.
Do we have any Newcastle United
supporters in the room?
Audience: Yeah!
RA: Yeah, there’s a couple there.
So, guys, I'm just going to warn you,
the next 10 minutes will be painful.
I know the last 25 years
have been painful,
but don't take this personally.
This is the stadium of Newcastle United,
St James' Park.
Every other week, 50,000
die-hard supporters
flock to the stadium
to watch their team play.
And instinctively, Newcastle United
has all the building blocks
to become a really
successful football club.
They got a billionaire businessman owner,
they got a fan base
most other clubs would die for.
But despite all that,
Newcastle is also known as the team
that never really fulfilled its potential.
But then a little bit more
than five years ago, in 2012,
the fortune seems to change for Newcastle
because they sensationally finished fifth
in the English Premier League,
the strongest league in the world.
That was an amazing achievement.
All the experts predicted Newcastle
to be battling [to] avoid relegation.
Now they were fifth.
Inside Newcastle,
the excitement was bubbling too.
The management team was convinced
this is the start of a new era
in the football club's history.
So they decided to reward the head coach
and his whole coaching staff
a historic-long, unbreakable
eight-year contract.
And they really tried to do everything
they could to keep the squad together
for the following season,
because that's how
successful organizations
are supposed to think, right?
The following season this happened.
Newcastle almost relegated.
They finished 16th,
and no one had a clue what was going on.
Because they had the same players,
they had the same coaching staff,
they even played in the same stadiums.
I mean, nothing's changed.
How could a largely unchanged team
go from fifth to 16th
in less than 12 months?
I'm going to try and answer that question.
But first, I’m going to give you
a little bit of background.
Because in football,
there’s a good old expression
that's frequently used by coaches,
players, commentators, experts.
It goes like this:
the league table never lies.
It kind of assumes that once the last game
of a season is played,
justice prevails.
The team that finishes top of the table
is the best-performing team,
and the teams that relegate
are the worst-performing teams.
At the end of the day,
everyone gets what they deserve.
It's not that simple, actually.
And let me explain why.
Please meet Matthew Benham.
He's a gambler.
He convinced me
the brightest guys in football
don't work for the football clubs.
They work in the gambling industry.
And I’m not talking
about the amateur gambler,
the guy that is placing a bet
every Saturday morning
to trigger his weekly rush of adrenaline.
I'm talking about the pros,
the guys that are using sophisticated
mathematical models to place the bets.
That's the brightest guys,
and Matthew is one of them.
He's an Oxford graduate in physics
that decided to set up his own
betting syndicate in North London,
basically an office
full of PhD statisticians
calculating the probabilities
for the outcome of football games.
That has made him a rich man.
So rich, he decided to buy
the football club
he supported since he was a teenager:
Brentford in West London.
And that's where I met him five years ago,
at Jersey Road, the training
ground of Brentford.
At the time we met,
Brentford was third in League One,
which is the third tier
of English football.
There was only five games
remaining of the season,
and Brentford was pushing for a promotion.
So I said to Matthew,
"What do you think?
Are you going to promote this season
and what does your gut feel say?"
He gave me an answer
I didn't quite expect.
It was not an answer full of excitement.
The guy just looked at me
and then he said, very dry,
“Well, at the moment there’s
a 42 percent chance we’ll promote.”
That comment made me realize
that I met someone
who thought completely different
about the game than I ever met before.
Over the next couple of months,
Matthew and I started
to meet regularly to exchange ideas
about how you could run
a football club differently.
In particular,
how would it be possible
to break the correlation
between spending and results
that seems to exist?
Is it possible to not outspend
but outthink the competition
by using the weapons of a gambler,
data and analytics?
One day we had lunch
at a restaurant together
in Soho in London,
and Matthew said to me he'd been looking
to buy another football club.
And I immediately responded,
"Why don't you take a look at the club
I supported when I was a teenager,"
FC Midtjylland,
based in the western rural Denmark,
in the middle of nowhere.
Midtjylland was almost broke at the time,
so it was a perfect place
to start testing radical ideas.
A week later, we flew to Denmark,
and we had a look at the club.
Eventually, he decided to buy the club.
He made me the chairman of the club,
and we've run the club together
for the past four years.
In the first season, we won the first
championship in the club’s history,
and a year later we became world-famous
because we beat
the mighty Manchester United
in the Europa League.
Unfortunately, in the UK,
that's more perceived
as the absolute embarrassment
of Manchester United
than the genius of Midtjylland,
but we will live with that.
(Laughter)
Suddenly, media, newspapers,
TV stations from all the world
were flying to western Denmark
to learn more about this little club
no one can pronounce the name of,
which is run by an English gambler
using data and analytics
to find a competitive edge.
So here's the thing.
If you want to understand
how a gambler thinks,
there’s one concept
you must get, it’s this:
the league table always lies.
Why is a gambler saying that?
Because he understands football
is a very random game.
It's a much more random game
than basketball, for example.
Why is that?
Because football is a low-scoring sport.
There's not a lot of goals in football.
No, the average number of goals
in a football game is 2.8.
The average number of goals
in a basketball games is above 200.
Here's the principle.
The fewer goals there is in a sport,
the more impact random events have.
Random events like the ball
getting deflected and spins into the net,
or the referee making a wrong call
in the last minute of the game.
Ultimately, this means that the best team
wins less often in football,
a low scoring-sport,
than in a high-scoring sport
like basketball.
And that's why the league table lies.
It lies more after ten games
than after 20 games.
But even 38 games, that is a full season,
38 games is a very small sample size.
You know, not enough to strip out
the randomness from the equation.
So a gambler is in the business
of making predictions
and backing those predictions
with his bets.
And when he decides
to back a team and place a bet,
he doesn't look at where that team is
in the league table.
He looks at underlying
performance indicators
that have more predictive value,
tells him more about where that team
is likely to go in the future
than its current league table position.
So let's go back
to Newcastle's glory season
when they finished fifth
and revisit that through
the lens of a gambler.
Because whereas experts in the game
were overly impressed
by Newcastle's performance,
the gamblers were very skeptical.
Their analysis showed
that this was a fragile bubble
that could burst any time.
Here's why.
One of the statistics
a gambler trusts a lot
is the statistic called goal difference.
It's the difference between
the number of goals a team scores
versus the number of goals
the opponent scores.
It's a very reliable indicator
for a team's strength.
So let's look at that.
Newcastle finished fifth
with a total shot
differential of plus-five.
A long way behind the four top teams.
And if you look at that column,
it's by far the lowest number.
This indicates what a gambler calls
an extremely effective goal distribution
All goes in football are important.
Not all goals are equally important.
So here's an example.
Let's say Newcastle scores
two goals over two games
and the opponent scores six goals.
Newcastle will be better off
winning 1-0 in the first game,
losing 6-1 in the second,
rather than losing twice 3-1.
Same goal difference
but different number of points.
So if a team is able to produce,
concede a number of goals
throughout the season,
how effective those scores
follow the goal distribution,
there's a big degree
of randomness to that.
And if you break down
Newcastle's 65 points this season,
you’ll see that it was driven
by a very effective goal distribution:
eight wins with one goal
and three major losses
with more than three goals.
It's very unlikely statistically
to be able to repeat 65 points
with a plus five goal difference.
Another statistic a gambler trusts
is something called shot differential:
the difference between the number
of shots a team produces
versus the number of shots
the opponent produces.
It's statistically very
well-documented in football
that the best team over time produces
more shots than the worst teams.
So let's have a look at that.
And as you can see,
Newcastle finished fifth
with a total shot differential of -1.4.
Clearly they don't belong in this company.
This indicates unsustainably high
conversion rate.
When you have a positive goal difference
driven by a negative shot differential,
it indicates unsustainably
high conversion rates.
How many of those shots
were converted to goals?
And Newcastle had
especially one player this season
who stood out, Cisse, their top scorer.
A key component of their success.
He converted 33 percent of his shots.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's a freaky number.
Here is how I would put it.
Newcastle's fifth place is the equivalent
of a publicly traded company
having a very high share price
and a very low customer satisfaction
at the same time.
You can have that for one year,
but you can't maintain that over time.
Here's a visualization of how a gambler
perceived the situation.
The black line shows the number
of points Newcastle achieved
throughout those two seasons
when they were fifth
and when there were 16th.
The red line is
the underlying performance,
what a gambler calls expected points.
So as you can see,
Newcastle got a lot more points
in the first season
when they finished fifth,
than the underlying performance justified.
Actually, Newcastle performed almost
the same way in those two seasons.
They just got less lucky.
And this reframes the original question.
Because why did Newcastle’s management
team not see this downturn coming?
Why did they decide to reward
the head coach with a historic, long,
unbreakable contract
when the results
were clearly unsustainable?
I believe that Newcastle was blinded
by one the most common
management delusions,
what psychologists call outcome bias.
The assumption that good results
are always the consequence
of good decisions
and superior performance.
Or, let’s put it in another way:
success turns luck into genius.
And this is where the message
becomes about much more
than just football analytics, right?
Because when an organization fails,
it becomes very natural for us
to dig for reasons,
to ask the tough questions.
Why did we fail?
How can we do things better?
But when we are successful,
we don't ask those questions.
We tend to just cruise on
blinded by outcome bias.
We expect results
to continue automatically.
We don’t dig into them and ask,
“What was actually the underlying
reason for the success?”
Was it because of the oil price?
Was it because of good leadership
or because of exceptional
market conditions?
How many companies do you think
confuse good leadership
with good market conditions?
Here's the thing.
Successful organizations should think
more like a good gambler.
Because a good gambler
has trained his brain
to resist the human tendency
to assume that good outcomes always mean
that someone acted brilliantly.
A good gambler treats success
with the same skepticism
as he treats failure.
And this is what successful
organizations should do too,
if they want to stay relevant:
ask themselves the questions of a gambler.
Why were we actually successful?
How do we separate luck from skill?
Is it possible that our league table
sometimes lied too?
Thank you very much.